السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره في مشهد صادم وثقته الكاميرات
لعمليه اعدام ميداني نشر ناشطون صور تظهر
قتلى شاب فلسطيني برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي جنوبيه نابلس من المسافه صفر
وحاول فلسطينيين تخليص شاب من قبضه الجندي
الذي اطبق الخناقه عليه وسحابه الى مكان
اخر واطلق النار عليه
وطلبت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه بحمايه دوليه
بما وصفته بجرائم منهجه الحكومات
الاسرائيليه
واعرضت الخارجيه الامريكيه عن قلقها من
استمرار العنف في الضفه الغربيه بدوره قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان العام الحالي هو
الاكثر دمويه في الضفه الغربيه منذ عام
2006 مطالبا بالتحقيق في وقوع ضحايا
مدنيين
طلب المستشار الالماني اوليف شولت صار
رئيس الروسيه الردمير بوتين بيتاحه فرصه
للحل دبلوماسيه عبر السحب قوته من
اوكرانيا من جهته قال الكريم لان اشتراطا
انسحاب روسيا من اوكرانيا غير ممكن مشددا
على ان قبوله مطالبها هو مفتاح الحل في
نادى على الرئيس تركيا طيب اردوغان الى
سرعه البحث عن ارضيه التفاوض مشتركه
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي للاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه جون كيربي ان الرئيس الروسيه
لم يظهر اي علامات على انه مستعد لان هذه
الحرب في اوكرانيا واضافها كلب بانه
واشنطن واحلى اساءها سيواصلون تقديم الدعم
لاوكرانيا لتمكينها من الدفاع عن نفسها
والتخفيف اثار الحرب على بقيه انحاء
العالم
قال المتحدث باسم القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه للجزيره انه نتيجه لاعلانه ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه توقف
عملياتها ضد تنظيم الدوله فقد قررت القوات
الامريكيه وقفا جميع عملياتها المشتركه ضد
التنظيم الشماليه سوريا وكنت وكاله رويترز
قد قالت عندما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه اعلنت تعليق التنسيق
والعمليات المشتركه مع التحالف الدولي
بقياده الولايات المتحده بعد القصف التركي
في ذلك بعد يومين من اعلان الانتاج
والتقليس دورياته في المنطقه
وقد دعى وزير الدفاع التركي خلص يا كار
حلفاء بلاده لقطع علاقاتهم ووقف دعمهم عن
وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه التي وصفها
بالارهابيه مؤكدا عزمي بلاده المضيق قدما
في عمليتها العسكريه
نقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصدر امني ان مسلحين
اطلق النار على مقر السفاره الباكستانيه
وسط العاصمه الافغانيه وافاد المصدر ان
اشتباكين بالاسلحه دار بين القوات الامنيه
وعدد من المهاجمين المتحصنين في مبنا يقل
على السفاره
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]